an animal shelter is looking to find a
forever home for some of their pets
after reaching near capacity they blame
the Ripple effects from the animal
foundation's issues among other factors
which has placed them in a troubling
situation
we definitely want to Foster and God
bless these people we met Nancy and art
Lair inside the Henderson Animal Care
and Control facility looking to adopt a
companion for their dog Rocky he needs a
partner and we want to be able to get
you know help a dog out
Animal Control administrator Danielle
Harney giving 8 news now a behind the
scenes tour of the facility she says
they are experiencing a high intake and
are quickly running out of space so many
people going back to work a lot of
people just don't have time for animals
and we're still honestly seeing a lot of
coveted returns and people are still
moving in and out of Vegas the small
staff facility near Boulder Highway and
Galleria has a variety of dogs of all
ages as well as cats fish rabbits
roosters and even Benedict the pig all
looking for a forever home we are the
only Municipal shelter in the city of
Henderson in order to surrender a pet to
us you have to be a city Henderson
resident so we do require proof of ID
when someone comes in to surrender their
pet however our open our adoptions are
open to anybody Harney says they do
about 30 adoptions per week but it's
still not enough to keep up with the
intake safety measures are fully
enforced she says to prevent a virus
spread and help people like this couple
find the perfect pet everything that we
do we do dogs and we always go to the
shelter because we just feel like
they're the ones that you know got the
bad end of the deal we love them and we
just want to you know adopt another dog
because we heard about all the you know
dogs that needs home around here
so many great animals out there all
right the animal shelter currently has
an adoption special for October all dogs
are one year and over our 45 dollars now
they have a large selection of animals
they don't require appointments only a
commitment to care for the pets